accord answer for hey guys I'm here with  look at these [ __ ] Dave and Ethan  then we just shot a video and this Park  Washington's Fair Park a lot of people  around here it's beautiful right really  picturesque there's this thing that's  beautiful it's like you're in France  almost and we shot a video where I tried  to be their wing woman and help them  pick up chicks ladies not chicken  that'd be bestiality gross and I feel  like I thoroughly embarrassed myself in  front of them hopefully hopefully 0-0  women knowing what have you got a  message on Facebook already from a girl  spoiler alert so that video is going to  go up soon next week ish this video is  going to go up what should be so fun we  also talked to a man that had no or no  he had a shirt on but he didn't have a  brain on did he told us that he was an  alien and he meant it and it was  wonderful look at the Sun yeah all that  vitamin Sun all right bye guys bye